[Music]
let's talk about the hangover part 3
I watched the movie I very much enjoyed
it
but I have to say it does feel like
you've been singled out in the cast by
todd phillips who directs the film's
it's almost like he singled you out and
he is pushing you he's trying to push
you to the edge you know more than
anyone else in the cast is that fair to
say well I mean you know he's a he's a
director that kind of makes you do
certain things that you don't really
want to do it's funny when we at the
time but that I have to deal with you
know when the movie comes out there was
a one in the first hangover where
there's in the slideshow they in
pictures where my character is getting
fellated by an old woman and I offer
Todd's assistant a thousand dollars to
get that out of the movie right and
turned out the lady was an old porn star
so she didn't have a problem with it so
ultimately I don't have a problem with
it if she was an old foreign star I just
thought she was an extra I was like oh I
feel so bad about this but turns out she
was fine with it she signed them with it
but yet Todd always has us doing like
bizarre things that end up on screen and
he is this true he he wasn't thrilled
that you you know lost some weight and
got healthy he wasn't thrilled with that
no he wanted me to gain my two ounces
back but yeah but it may in the in the
in hangover 3 I'm wearing a fat suit I
didn't know that yeah I'm wearing one
now too
you actually weigh nine times where nine
pounds yeah
now we're happy with the way the film
turned out were you or do you have any
concepts or preconceived notions of what
the hangover 3 should be well I thought
the hangover 3 should just be the three
of us like playing Parcheesi and nothing
happens that would have been just you
guys playing a board game and nothing
happened that's it that's it but the
hangover 3 that's coming out is the best
one of the three it really is it's gonna
be really great it's got a lot of funny
stuff in it this is the last one are you
gonna miss playing Alan which one is
Alan I will miss playin Alan because
it's a it's one of those things where
he's so stupid that he can say anything
and it doesn't matter it doesn't have to
make sense so yeah give it a given I
mean it's such a character I can't it'll
be sad it'll be sad to let him go but
you know you seem broken up about it
yeah nobody is funny I like that he's
also it's one of my favorite comedy
blends is he's really stupid and
arrogant yeah yeah that's my favorite
simply telling everyone else off yeah
that's my having no clue I love arrogant
people that are that are stupid that's
my we have a clip here from The Hangover
Part 3 and I believe this is when the
three of you are finding out where you
next need to go you're sort of on a
mission yes that's right and you're
finding out okay we now know where we're
gonna go
that's correct let's take a clip thank
you I studied hard for this let's say
it's good for The Hangover Part 3 he
wants to meet Alan tonight at 8:00 just
come along come on where a bus stop a
Tijuana Tijuana is de bomb
oh no that's perfect that's like a
three-hour drive from here yes to try
reading a map yeah Alan try reading
anything ever yes do try not having such
a big horse teeth
is this
we're really raising the bar what it
does feel like you and Ed Helmes you
have a relationship a little bit like
that in real life don't you oh well
there's a lot of meeting there's a lot
of jokes back and forth about the size
of Ed's teeth and like I'll I'll text
ahead a picture and my text will read
hey I just saw the poster for hangover 3
you look great in it and then I'll send
him a picture of a horse he gets mad at
me but he gets an applause